I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to our
edition of Melina masters I believe that
the fastest and most effective way to
grow a business is to model the
strategies of people who have already
done what you're trying to do so today
we're going to look at how a boy who was
born in the streets of Harlem and who
nobody thought would amount to much turn
his life around and became one of the
most well known musicians producers and
entertainers this is a story of Grammy
award-winning entrepreneur Sean Combs
and a top three lessons you can learn
from his success Sean Combs was born in
Harlem New York City the Janis and
Melvin combs Combs's early life was a
far cry from the luxurious existence
he's grown accustomed to since at the
age of two combs his life would change
forever his Street hustling father was
gunned down leaving Janis to raise combs
and his sister on her own fearful of the
increasing danger harlem posed to her
children janice moved the family to
Mount Vernon New York this she believed
would provide the children a safer
environment in which to grow up without
the support of her husband Janice was
forced to work three jobs in order to
not only provide for her kids but to be
able to give them the best education
possible after graduating from high
school Combs moved to Washington DC to
ten Howard University where pursued a
degree in business administration his
attention slowly began to shift from
inside the classroom to outside on the
streets its ultra muriel instincts
started to kick in and soon he was
producing weekly dance parties and
running an airport shuttle service
however the age of 21 Combs decided to
create a company of his own in the
entertainment business with help from
Arista Records founder Clive Davis Combs
was able to create his own music label
Bad Boy Entertainment a few of the acts
he had previously signed to uptown
including Christopher Wallace aka the
notorious b.i.g and Craig Mack signed on
the Combs's new company allowing Combs
to hit the ground running in its first
year the young label released Mack's
flavor in a year which proved to be a
huge success this was followed with
albums by b.i.g which also went on to
become multi-platinum in 2002 Combs was
named one of the 40 richest people on
the forty by Fortune magazine with the
current estimated net worth of over
three hundred million dollars Combs has
become something of an American icon and
against all odds one of the country's
most successful entrepreneurs
by trusting his entrepreneurial
instincts and by having a courage to
follow them Combs was able to go from
the streets of Harlem into becoming one
of the most successful entrepreneurs in
the entertainment industry to help you
explode your business here are three
action items and you can learn from Sean
Combs action item number one work hard
modern success will help ensure that
you're focusing on the right tasks but
you still have to do the work starting
and running a business is one of the
most challenging things you'll ever do
in your life so commit to giving it your
best don't give up when things don't go
your way
focus on helping your target audience
and giving them incredible value with
hard work and time you'll get there
never one to shun hard work Combs is
willing to do whatever it took to get
his business off the ground and keep it
there he was a workaholic even from his
early entrepreneurial days at Howard
University and always made his business
ventures his number one priority eager
to succeed at Uptown records combs often
sacrifice both his academics and the
social life in order to rise in the
ranks of the business world he
frequently shuddered back between New
York City and Washington DC trying to
balance both school and work
it was his dedication and hard work that
marked his rise to the top which is one
of the most rapid ascents in a history
of the music industry according that
Combs
I came in to win this is why I stay up
late while other people are sleeping
this is why I don't go out to the
Hamptons I've never been surprised about
what's happened to me I've put in hard
work to get to this point it's like when
you become a lawyer if you're busting
your ass you're not surprised when you
get your degree this is my plan when I'm
in the studio making a hit record I'm
not trying to make a hit record I'm
making one this is what I studied this
is why I stay up 20 hours a day I'm
trying to be somebody I didn't come into
this business saying I'm going to look
like the biggest black man in music I
was like I'm going to be the biggest I'm
going to go down in history as being one
of the best music men and business men
in entertainment
action the number to take risks if you
wait until you have all the information
you need to make a decision you'll be
too late you don't have to be a gambler
to be an entrepreneur but you have to be
willing to take calculated risks bet on
yourself and have the confidence to know
that you can succeed at whatever you do
if you put your mind to it
from the very first day Combs began his
internship at Uptown records he had it
in the back of his mind that one day he
would start his own company he wasn't
even thinking on the scale of Uptown
Combs wanted to be bigger as big as they
come and he knew that in order to get
there he couldn't do it alone with the
likes of Clive Davis and the notorious
b.i.g I decide come set out to achieve
his goals he did it by pushing a limits
what was expected to this end com said
out about revolutionising the music
industry by exploring new territory in a
fresh concept Combs had his 1997 hip hot
hit single it's all about the Benjamins
reworked by Rob Zombie and David Grohl
to create a hugely successful Rock remix
he also surprised many by sampling
musics from the likes of David Bowie in
the police mixing them with his light
rap rhythms combs was never afraid to
take risks whether it was with his music
or with his other business ventures from
his music to his clothing lines his
restaurants Combs has been a risk-taker
who sets high goals and takes
extraordinary steps to achieve them he
seeks out unexplored in new territories
and tries to make them his own
according to Combs I admire Andre
Harrell and Barry Gordy the most the
people who came up from the black
community the people that I'm going to
be greater than are Steven Spielberg
David Geffen and Clive Davis you have to
invest in executive talent in order to
one day own or be part of a fortune 500
company I'm more mature now I understand
it's alright to need people you got to
mix it up I give it to Madonna for
changing her styles never being too
predictable going in different
directions keep on pushing the
boundaries and reaching for higher
heights if you try if you give it your
all you go with what's in your heart
octoman Oh number three focus focus
focus
entrepreneurs love getting distracted
new opportunities will constantly
bombard you and it's easy to get excited
about them long-term success comes from
committing to an idea and carrying it
through until you've reached your goal
focus your energy and have the courage
to say no to new ideas that don't
support your current business between
all his business ventures marathon runs
and his family if it wasn't for Combs
his ability to focus on one important
thing at a time
he would have succumbed to the pressure
long ago in 2003 combs made up his mind
that he was going to run in the New York
City Marathon one of the top annual
long-distance running events in the u.s.
comprised of a 26.2 mile course through
the five boroughs of the city a first
for Combs his goal is to raise 1 million
dollars for New York City school system
for 8 straight weeks combs trained
around the clock to be ready for the
race at mile 12 of the race combs his
legs seized and his physician was unsure
if he could continue but combs remain
focused on his goal he had managed to
raise 2 million dollars in donation
double his initial goal and he was not
about to let his supporters or the chill
of New York City down he made the mental
decision to commit to his goal and
finish the race no matter what the cost
this is what he did four hours later
according to columns I'm a very focused
person right now I'm in a real strong
creative zone you know music claim in
the zone
fashion designer wise I'm in that zone
I'm in a zone right now I'm like Jordan
in the 4th right now ladies and
gentlemen you can't really know where
you're going in life is a person let
alone a culture community if you don't
take the time to sit back evaluate and
analyze the successes and the mistakes
try to figure out how to learn from them
and move forward by setting goals and
agendas for yourself
so remember work hard take risks and
focus focus focus to finish up this
video I wanted to share one of my
favorite true stories about Sean Combs
and some of his best quotes Sean Combs
has branched out into a lot of
businesses but one thing he said he was
always afraid of was acting in front of
people he believed that you must change
he become better even as a person this
could be why he's changed his name so
many times however when it came to
acting he was not as confident he first
appeared in several guest roles and then
made his big-screen appearance as a drug
dealer in made after working hard on his
acting he period another move with Billy
Bob Thornton and Halle Berry called
monsters ball but he would not stop
there he worked hard in his acting and
appeared on Broadway in several
productions then created his own
production company where he began
producing several reality TV shows all
of which were hits
whatever Combe seems that put his mind
to it is successful because he works
hard to learn everything about the
business
you
thank you for joining me for another
edition of modeling masters if you like
the video and you want to see more
please give it a thumbs up below what
makes me want to do more of these videos
for you guys I'd also love to hear what
you have to thank you've run leave a
comment under the video I always check
those out and it means a lot to me when
you do so thank you and we'll see you on
the next episode